اظن ان انت تعرف جامعه هارفرد صح جامعه
هارفرد مشهوره جدا تخيل بقى ان انت ممكن
تبقى عايش في الشرق الاوسط وبتاخد كورسات
من جامعه هارفرد والاكثر من كده ان انت
ممكن تحضر الكورسات دي مجانا من غير ما
تدفع اي فلوس تعال اوريك هتدخل على الموقع
في الال دوت
في 113 كورس متاحين مجانا للتعلم مثلا
الكورس بتاع الكمبيوتر الكورس مدته 11
ساعه وتقدر تتعلم اي وقت انت عايزه بالليل
الصبح العصر اي وقت لان التعلم اونلاين عن
طريق فيديوهات هي اوريدي متسجله الكورسات
اللي موجوده دي مش كورسات اي تي بس لا في
كورسات لها علاقه بالبيزنس في كورسات ليه
علاقه بتسعير المنتجات استراتيجي وكورسات
تانيه كتير حضور الكورسات مجاني لكن لو
انت عايز تحصل على الشهاده هتحتاج ان انت
تدخل الامتحان وتدفع فلوس اكيد الكورسات
بتاعه هيبقى شكلها حلو قوي عندك في السي
في ما تنساش ان انت تشارك الفيديو ده مع
صحابك اكيد حد فيهم نفسه ياخد كورس من
جامعه هارف